Goodwill more like ill will
on the surface Goodwill seems like the
Friendly Neighborhood Thrift Store focus
on giving back to the community and
fighting inequality
on paper they're a non-profit that isn't
owned by anyone which means no
shareholders no stock and hopefully no
anti-consumer Behavior
their board of directors is actually
filled with a bunch of volunteers so
theoretically their only goal would be
to give back to the community which they
do do in several ways they have a bunch
of career programs that help
underprivileged people and make some
cash and learn new skills they're also
one of the only organizations out there
that will hire people with disabilities
aside from the government they've also
been around for quite some time as
Goodwill has been around for over a
hundred and twenty years which means
that they've donated tens of billions if
not hundreds of billions of dollars to
charitable services
in fact in 2018 alone they pulled in 6.1
billion dollars in Revenue out of which
5.27 billion was spent on it charitable
services
so they're doing a great job right well
yes and no there are definitely
commendable portions of Goodwill and I
don't want to take away from that but
there is also a lot of reprehensible
portions as well for one Goodwill isn't
even all that charitable in the first
place Goodwill claims that 82 of the
revenue goes towards programs and
services for people in need some regions
even have percentages as high as 90
percent but this is largely misleading
as this does not mean that 82 or 90 of
the money that you spend at Goodwill
actually goes to charity in fact there's
evidence that as little as 1 8 of their
profit actually goes to the main
programs that they advertise also you
know how Goodwill employees disable the
people well this may be more
exploitative than generous you see there
are special laws that allow
organizations to pay disabled people as
little as 22 to 41 cents per hour which
is already quite bad but it doesn't stop
there disabled employees also don't have
these same protections that everyone
else does which makes them the perfect
scapegoats to hand off dangerous tasks
to and when it comes to whistleblowers
and employees fighting back Goodwill may
as well just be a private Corporation as
that's how they behave they usually
threaten fire and publicly discredited
people that fight back
so here's the truth about Goodwill and
why you should think twice before
donating to or purchasing from Goodwill
jumping straight into the donations
Goodwill claims that they spend between
80 and 90 of the revenue on charitable
services and technically speaking this
is probably accurate asper touched on in
2018 Goodwill pulled in 6.1 billion
worth of Revenue and donated 5.27
billion
so that falls right in line with about
86 of the revenue being donated but this
doesn't mean what you think it means
any normal person would probably think
that this means that for every dollar
you spend at Goodwill 86 Cents gets
donated or at least maybe for every
dollar they profit if they donate 86
cents but neither of these are true of
the reality is that much of Goodwill's
charitable spending it isn't even funded
by us the customers it's actually funded
by various government organizations
take Goodwill Omaha for instance they
have a bunch of job training and
assistance programs but nearly all of
these activities were funded by
government grants and contracts and you
know they're programmed to employ
disabled people well that was primarily
funded by school districts it turns out
that out of the four million dollars
worth of profit generated by the region
only 557 000 or a little more than an
eighth was spent on these Flagship job
programs and keep in mind that's profit
not Revenue only 1 8 of The Profit is
being spent on these programs so imagine
how little of the consumer-based revenue
it ends up at these programs but then
where are all these profits going
instead people are literally donating
items for free so surely Goodwill
shouldn't have too many manufacturing or
shipping or sourcing expenses well the
official destination is Administrative
overhead but that's just a fancy term
for large executive compensation
Goodwill actually has a history of
paying Executives super large salaries
in 2014 for example they paid their CEO
Frank McCree at 933 thousand dollars
this actually won him so much criticism
and backlash that he would end up
resigning but things haven't exactly
gotten better
his successors were paid a base salary
of 434 thousand dollars and there are
rumors that total compensation reached
as high as 1.1 million dollars though
Goodwill does dispute the total
compensation numbers either way though
Executives and high-level managers are
being paid multiple six figures the in
fact change.org claims that the top
managers at 150 Goodwill locations are
being paid more than 30 million dollars
also some of these people don't seem to
have any issue charging a bunch of
personal expenses onto corporate cars
former CFO Tim Leggett for example
charged over 75 000 worth of personal
purchases onto a Goodwill corporate card
so yeah that's where much of the profit
is going also for the record I have no
issue with people making a lot of money
if you want to make a lot of money go to
a private company or start your own
business don't leech off of a non-profit
also one more thing about these
Executives is that many of them are
politicians by trade the current CEO
Steve Preston for example was the
Secretary of Housing and Urban
Development under President George Bush
and the former CEO Jim kibbons was part
of the White House Council for Community
Solutions under President Barack Obama
so take that for what you will
but it's not just your donations that
Goodwill is exploiting they're also
exploiting the people who work there
one of the trademarks of Goodwill is
providing jobs to underprivileged people
and especially people with disabilities
but once again this isn't as great as it
sounds it's actually really bad
you see Goodwill leverages an archaic
role found in the fair labor standards
act which was passed way back in 1938
section 14c of the ACT basically allows
companies to legally pay disabled
workers wages that are lower than
minimum wage
this has resulted in disabled people in
Pennsylvania earning as little as 22
cents 38 cents and 41 cents per hour
Goodwill claims that these are outlier
cases and they're probably right about
that but just because the average
disabled worker isn't making these
absurdly low wages doesn't mean that
they're making good wages either also I
wanted to point out that it's not just
Goodwill that's exploiting these rules
either basically every organization that
hires disabled workers other than the
government leverages tactic disabled
workers at Applebee's for example were
making 397 to 596 per hour and disabled
workers at Barnes Noble were making 380
to 485 per hour
so it's kind of an industry-wide problem
and it doesn't seem like it will be
fixed anytime soon either Goodwill has
actually fought against proposals that
suggest raising the minimum wage
the reasoning is that they simply can't
afford to pay employees anymore which
doesn't really make sense when you
consider how much their Executives make
and how little actually gets donated
but not only does Goodwill pay disabled
workers low wages they also expect a lot
of work in fact disabled workers are
sprayed up tested for their
effectiveness disabled employees have to
take A time test to see how quickly they
can sort and hang clothes the ideal rate
is 100 garments within 32 minutes for
most people this is a pretty reasonable
Target but if you're blind for example
this becomes exponentially harder and if
you don't reach this target your hourly
wage gets deducted proportionately this
is how you end up with employees making
ridiculously low wages one blind a
Goodwill employee named Sheila leglin
for example was already only making 309
per hour but Goodwill wanted to reduce
this to 275 an hour Sheila wouldn't just
end up quitting but this is not a luxury
that most disabled workers have so
they're just stuck making 275 an hour
Goodwill claims that there are not
exploiting workers and that they're
actually providing opportunity as 80
have disabled people in the US don't
have any opportunity at all but pity
jobs that milk these people for the
lowest wages possible isn't the same as
truly uplifting and supporting the
disabled Community as Alice put it at
least we gave them jobs is not a
progressive socially responsible move
[Music]
if you didn't think that exploiting
disabled workers was bad enough well it
gets even worse as Goodwill has been
linked with several workplace debts
Goodwill's PR and the legal team loved
to write off these debts as tragic
incidents that were not their fault but
when you take a look at the evidence
that story becomes a lot harder to
believe take former Goodwill employee
David goody for example Dave only worked
at Goodwill for a mere six months as a
waste management driver but let's just
say that he went to Helen Back during
their short tenure one day during his
shift he noticed that the trailer brakes
weren't working when activated from the
cab so as a responsible driver he would
pull over shut down the truck and call
management he was hoping that Goodwill
would send out a technician who could
fix the issue but instead they just sent
out another driver that was willing to
drive the truck despite the issue this
was no doubt jarring for Dave and he
would of course go ahead and file
complaints to Goodwill regarding this
incident but this was by no means the
only safety hazard that he noticed he
also noticed a major safety hazard
regarding Goodwill's trash compactors he
reported a quote based on my personal
observations most employees now
operating compactors at each plant have
it not received the required training he
would go on to warn that this could
result in injuries deaths and fines
which could all be completely avoided if
proper training was implemented but as
fate would have it Goodwill would take
no action and a 26 year old employee
named Abraham Garza would be killed by a
trash compactor just a few weeks later
this would have been a good time for
Goodwill to apologize to David for not
taking his complaints more seriously but
instead it they would fire Dave and to
blame the incident on Abraham kalosha
would eventually step in and Define
Goodwill 106 thousand dollars but even
after that Goodwill would continue to
maintain that they were not liable if
this was a one-off incident they would
have some plausible deniability but it
could will actually has a history of
on-site injuries in 2008 a 27 year old
was crushed to death by a trash
compactor lift in 2014 a 69 year old was
crushed by a forklift and in 2017 a 54
year old was killed by another forklift
and the worst part is that many of these
deaths are amongst disabled workers you
see employers aren't as liable for
disabled workers because the disability
may increase the chances of a workplace
injury so Goodwill is a literally
incentivized to place disabled workers
in dangerous jobs and it seems like that
is exactly what they're doing leading to
many disabled workers literally been
killed
those are just a few of the most notable
issues at Goodwill but there by no means
the only issues for example another
major critique against Goodwill is that
they send clothes that they can sell in
Western countries to developing
countries and given that these were
donated items they can sell these
clothes for super cheap which screws up
the local clothing Industries and the
only reason that Goodwill is able to get
away with so much is because they're a
non-profit if a for-profit company like
Amazon was exploring disabled workers by
paying them ridiculously low wages and
exposing them to significant workplace
risk they would be crucified by public
opinion but since Goodwill is a
non-profit slash charity these issues
often get glossed over
now again this isn't to say that
Goodwill is completely evil like big
Pharma or something they do do some
awesome things but they've also got some
major issues that have been ignored for
way too long and just maybe if we bring
enough attention to these issues we can
actually get them to change but that's
just what I think do you think Goodwill
is really good at will or it will
comment that down below also drop a like
if you would like to see more videos
exposing the Dark Side of such
organizations and of course consider
checking out our Discord Community such
as the video ideas and consider
subscribing to see more questions that
logically answered but until then I'm
Hari and I'll see you guys on the next
one